do not say nasty site Mason go yard got
the necessities several necessities no
lotion deodorant long always got
something to say music all like a beast
fear I was laying dead in here various
charges laptop no manners [ __ ] like that
[Music]
look keep all right here it's a Bentley
truck water sleep hopefully but it's not
always there that's it man you know I'll
take so much maintenance no you don't
have hit me demands that [ __ ] like that
all tomorrow
this is a skeleton playing with rose
gold I use wife's got this time I gotten
into like past couple years just
collecting on keep it it's very soon
[Music]
partner but um I pray before every so
about yours yeah I like it like yeah
most uh most of the stuff is in custody
I get all done up here in New York
that's our family all of them cuz
they're like much
[Music]
do they and I didn't never heard of the
second suit that's great
so in second this is a premier shot on
my command
I'm that kind of guy man you know I'm
sad love jackets outerwear I [ __ ] goings
on the t-shirt I'm big on that kind of
stuff
yeah a low fall fall winter fake well we
all wait for there's some ones that like
knit assumption
don't say that say that pulling over day
and night tomorrow drama way these with
the yellow track pass you guys
[Music]